okay as many of you know i am not a
christian i truly don't understand
that much about christianity but i do
feel like i have a sense of crazy when i
see it
and today i have video for you of pastor
dan
burgoyne from california playing with
dog poop
shoving his hands into dog poop during a
sermon to i guess make some kind of
point about sin
or something like that now i want to
warn people if you're having breakfast
if you're having lunch whatever you're
doing there there is going to be video
here of the pastor
doing scatological play with dog poop
on stage during a sermon now the con
there isn't there shockingly there is
there is context here
um which is my discussion yesterday of
the tax exemption that churches receive
in the united states i didn't i
mentioned it offhandedly
but i got a ton of emails from people
talking about david i agree or i
disagree with your point about churches
and tax exemptions so
warning we are going to look at a video
here in which this guy is playing with
dog poop
check out the build-up to this stunt and
importantly consider whether this type
of thing
is what we the taxpayers should be
subsidizing
so that churches can do this and yet not
pay taxes but not pay taxes let's take a
look so do you know what god
equates as sin in the bible
he equates poop
filth whoa in the bible no this is not a
brownie
no this is not snickers bar i own tubal
mastiffs in my life
this is great dane your god
do you know how what a crappy idea guys
god sees now listen this is important
psalm 141 verse 2 may my
prayer be set before you like what like
incense may the lifting of my hands be
like the evening sacrifices
your sin god says has hidden my face
from you
so that i will not hear so when you
come in and you're saying god the gods
of my life compete with who you
are but i'm declaring that i belong are
you guys understanding how
this is building up to smearing himself
with dog poop because i'm not
you god says this is what i see
whoa really trying to score some brownie
points with god we might say
and what i see comes up like incense
before me
oh my god and what's going on in your
soul i can see in ways nobody he's
playing with it like clay now you can
see
and so you know what you say oh god
created me a clean heart and renewing me
a right
spirit and cast me not from thy presence
and
take not thy holy spirit from me and you
got chunks
coming off of your thumb and god is
saying what do you want
do you want me or do you want you do you
want
your ways or do you want my ways because
you can't have
what you're getting the weight okay what
a crappy way to make a point don't you
think
so that's that's a church they're
tax-exempt
a bregoin quotes psalm 141
i guess it's verse 2 or line 2
about lifting one's hands up to god
i think maybe the point he's trying to
make is that
we are merely dog poop without god or or
something like that
um so what is this desperation is this
mental illness
is that what is it is it grifting of
some kind
and at some point if you're spending
your sunday
digging through your own dog's poop on
church in a church on a stage
don't you have to reconsider whether god
has
laid out a good life for you at some
point isn't that a question is this what
god wants you to be doing
playing with poop on a in a church
and um this is what gets me back again
to the blanket tax exemption for
churches i get it if a church runs a
soup kitchen
organize it separately give them a tax
exemption
if a church even runs a school even if
it's a religious education if they're
doing
good education otherwise and teaching
real stuff
let them organize as a non-profit
educational institution
but we have millions of people who are
lacking health care we have hunger in
the united states we have people without
homes etc
but this guy gets a tax exemption for
schadological games
something is very very wrong and i
remain convinced that the blanket tax
exemption for churches
needs to be done away with i'm not
saying there are situations
i'm not saying there aren't situations
where it makes sense that a church would
be tax exempt
but this stuff has to stop this stuff
absolutely has to stop send me your
thoughts
and um you know just just a crappy story
to go to break on here